hi there i'm rayne wilson and i'm reza
aslan and this is metaphysical milkshake
don't you mean i'm dr reza aslan
yeah i mean i guess but i suppose come
on don't be shy mr smarty pants
let's go for everyone tuning in raza
doesn't talk about it a lot but he is
actually a doctor a phd
um speaking of which i have this weird
rash i want to show you
no no no no keep your shirt on i'm not
that kind of a doctor as you well know
it says it on your wikipedia page which
i read
all the time and i update constantly no
no i'm not i'm not like
i'm not like a doctor like the way dr oz
is a doctor by which i don't mean i am
you know a snake oil salesman uh i'm i'm
a different i'm the useless kind of
doctor
i have a phd in sociology
how about a waste of time okay listen
potato potato listen you're you got edu
an education a serious education you're
one of the
wisest people i know well so i'm still
going to show you my rash
so as much as as much as i want to see a
rash
you don't don't confuse uh education
with wisdom right i mean that's that's a
they're two completely different things
just because you're educated
does not mean that you are wise
there is yes my friend i know this is a
this is a revelation to you but there is
a difference between
simply being erudite and uh and being
wise
yeah in fact okay even though even
though i am smart enough
to use big words like erudite
uh frankly if i were to be honest with
myself
not that wise okay yeah no that is
making sense i'm putting the puzzle
pieces together because
didn't over your kid's spring break you
guys or a little while ago you purchased
a
33 year old rv and then decided to go on
a cross-country trip
with the wife and the four children and
then the brakes fell off
and the engine imploded and you were
stranded
stranded in bakersfield for two weeks
during that
said spring break almost everything you
said was right except that it was a 40
year old rv
and we got stranded in vacaville but yes
that's a very good case in point right
there
okay there wow you are so unwise reza
oh my god thank you there's such a
distinction between intelligence and
wisdom
so what is wisdom
welcome to metaphysical milkshake the
show where we go deep we get weird
and we search for the meaning of life
along the way presented by cast media
and soul pancake all right so
what is wisdom what is it how do you get
it
can you find it in a fortune cookie and
why has western civilization which
values information and intelligence
and knowledge seem to have disregarded
this very
important concept of wisdom yes very
good question
and one that i don't have the answer to
as i have already
clearly demonstrated uh this is all way
too complex for my limited
cerebral cortex so we need someone else
someone way wiser
than either of us that will help us wrap
our heads
around it and i think i think you and i
both know the right person for this
don't we
mike pence how about
journalist author and now entrepreneur
krista tippett oh trista tibbett much
better idea she is the host of the
hugely popular public radio program and
podcast
on being her books include einstein's
god
conversation about science and human
spirit and becoming wise she wrote a
book on wisdom
an inquiry into the art of living
she's got a national humanities medal
from uh president barack obama wow like
kind of a big deal i said it's a big
deal yeah and now she has this new
app that we're going to talk about the
on being app
where you know you can just kind of uh
engage uh
with the the wisdom of her many many
years hosting one of the most
popular uh npr programs
uh about life and and because she's
basically we are just a knockoff
of on being i mean we might as well just
admit that we are
we're pale we're in paris we're a cheap
knockoff
yep without further ado uh let's bring
on our guest
krista tippett krista tippett welcome to
metaphysical milkshake
i'm glad to be with you wow i i have to
say like just hearing your voice and
seeing your face is such a thrill for me
because
uh i think you know i'm just the hugest
fan of your
show i've i've heard at least two-thirds
of every episode
that you've done and i don't mean
two-thirds of the way through i mean
two-thirds of the actual recorded
episodes but
uh i've listened to two-thirds of of my
episode
and i oddly enough i skipped reza's
episode
thanks i'm nervous are you nervous i
feel a little nervous
interviewing krista tippett like about
you know life and spirituality and
existential
issues uh you know i i really feel like
i got to be on my
on my best game here christa welcome to
the show i'm
really longtime listener first time
caller and uh excited to be speaking to
you about this and when we first
brought you up as a possible subject to
discuss
wisdom our our thinking was oh this is
such an exciting tapestry that christa
tippett has
has spoken to dozens or hundreds of the
wisest people
on the planet and i'm just thrilled to
be having this conversation but
before we get to that um because we want
to dig
into the root of what wisdom is
i'm going to turn the tables on you a
little bit and ask you the first
question
that you always pose to your guests
which is what kind of religious or
spiritual environment
did you grow up in oh take that
my my grandfather was a southern baptist
preacher
and i grew up in an immersive religious
environment
i was in church three times a week and
only southern baptists were going to
heaven not even methodists
wow
my grandfather was a really complicated
character
he he was passionate and he was
terrified of passion
he had a beautiful mind and he had a
second grade education and he hadn't
really
been invited to bring his mind his the
life of his mind
to religion and um
i've moved so far away from that
religious sensibility
but there's a lot that i that
that formed me and there's a way in
which i sometimes feel like
i ask these questions i ask and speak to
scientists and
speak to people of many traditions and
and speak about
uh speak to people who are not religious
about crafting lives of meaning and i
kind of i feel like i do that on behalf
of my grandfather who would never have
dared ask those questions
yeah i mean that religious world of my
childhood was
all about answers it wasn't just about
answers but it was hugely defined by
answers and to me what became
fascinating is
the questions that are behind that
animate this part of life and that
animate the traditions
and that animate human beings
so that background is in me but in some
ways i
i um i feel like i'm going where it
didn't go
at least that world of my childhood that
reminds me of that famous
uh rilke quote about
uh loving the questions themselves
you have listened to my show because i i
quote real good just about every other
episode
oh you guys in your rilke he is my
namesake krista
rain uh my my dad wanted to name me
rainer
after rachel i wanted to name my son
rainer
going to the quote itself uh try to love
the questions themselves
as if they were locked rooms or books
written in a very foreign language
yes don't search for the answers which
could not be given you now because you
would not be able to live them
and the point is to live everything live
the questions
now perhaps then someday far in the
future
you will gradually without even noticing
it live your way
into the answer that seems very
relevant yeah live your way to the
answer i love that
well it also seems very relevant to
this moment we inhabit i think
what we're what we're faced with what
we're coming out of
the last year with our
big aching open questions that have no
answers yet that we have
to and you know that that uh so rilke
you know rilke was also a
turn-of-century person he was
he was a and a citizen of the last early
century which also had its huge
tumult behind and ahead um
and yeah i think the piece of it that
i've lived into
lived into um because i always speak
like that because i
that that saying is so important to me
is that when we don't have the answers
we are called to live
the questions and hold the questions and
love the questions
and that's never felt more true to me
than it does in 2021.
you're right rayne it's like a perfect
segue into the
topic of this conversation which is what
is wisdom and
and you know there's a million answers
to that question and obviously
you're here because we want to
understand your answer to it you've
thought about this a lot you've spoken
to so many wise people you've written
about the topic
but just before we get diving
into it it does feel like so much about
whatever wisdom is is about learning to
ask
questions right and and being open to
to the possibility of of there not
necessarily being an
answer it's something we know something
we've all experienced in life
it's also true in science that the
quality of our answers
is very much determined by the quality
of the questions we're asking
i mean culturally we're not very patient
with dwelling with questions
but i think that's a very it's a common
experience if we look
back i mean i saw you know i wrote this
book called becoming wise few years ago
and i realized after the book was
finished that i had not
in the entire book defined wisdom so i
did come up with a definition okay let's
do that this is great
this is a great opportunity so what is
wisdom yeah
how do we how do we recognize wisdom
i think wisdom is different from
knowledge or accomplishment
although a wise person can be
knowledgeable and accomplished
um because those are possessions those
are things you can point at and
quantify i think though wisdom is
measured
by the imprint a person makes on the
world around them so that that that's
that and i again i think we all
if you ask anyone to cast their mind to
who are the who are the wise people in
the worlds you've inhabited
what you think of is their presence and
what you think of is how that life
radiated around them and these are often
you know these there are people like
this in every
in every world large and small they're
not necessarily famous people they're
not necessarily officially wise people
um they're everywhere right this
einstein had this language of spiritual
geniuses
and he was talking about the buddha and
moses
and jesus and saint francis of assisi
and reza
obviously they're also spiritual
geniuses of the every day
and uh and that's another way to think i
think about the wise people
we've experienced you uh referred
uh previously and you had a great quote
about how
uh everyone grows old but not everyone
grows
wise some people just grow old
you you believe that wisdom is
attainable
and i and i often talk to people when i
talk about spirituality i always talk
about like
you know the old people that's like the
grumpy old guy who's like
get off my lawn and who's racist and
closed-minded like we know that those
we've met those types before usually in
trader joe's parking lots
and then um and then there's the wise
the wise loving old person who seems to
have had
their heart expanded and um
give love and radiate something and it's
a very
clear that there are these two paths but
you believe that it's attainable what do
we do
to uh turn into option number two what
do we do to attain
that kind of wisdom well sadly there's
not a 10-point plan
um and i really know it's it's
really it's life to life moment to
moment um
the circumstances are going to be
different
but it's about the quality of your
presence
and you know another thing that we're
learning
and i love that we're learning this
through science is
that you know basically what what we
practice we become
that that the same thing is true of you
know
learning to play the piano or throw a
ball that we can actually
practice qualities of character
um you don't i i think
people in the 20th century grew up
thinking that you
you know you're born a hospitable person
or a patient person or a loving person
or a compassionate person i think people
still have that idea
this this is something that goes wrong
with when we put wise people up on
pedestals
um but what we're learning now is you
know you can actually
cultivate qualities of character you can
you can decide to act like a patient
person
and you can there been become more
patient
you can act like a hospitable person or
a compassionate person
and you're actually creating muscle
memory
and you know i don't think the wise that
wise grandmother you know i don't i i
don't think
that's not that's not always the path
people have taken of um
gritting their teeth and because that's
what that sounds like
um but i think it is a
you know maybe you could say it's a
vision of what kind of person you want
to be and what kind of world you want to
live in and
and then you could also say that that
you live
into that question that possibility
you know cbd isn't about what you feel
it's about what you
don't feel stress anxiety
pain all that bad stuff i tried the
feels
feels brand cbd oil and man did it help
me sleep sometimes i just
simply cannot go to bed my brain is
bouncing around like a bunch of monkeys
in a popcorn popper
and it really helped a lot feels is a
premium cbd
that will help keep your head clear and
feel your best it's hassle-free it's
delivered directly to your door
cbd naturally helps reduce stress
anxiety pain
and sleeplessness there's no hangover or
addiction
all you got to do is place a few drops
of fields under your tongue
and you'll feel the difference within a
few minutes and the thing to remember
about cbd is that
finding your right dose is super
important and everybody's dose is going
to be different
my dose is going to be different than
rayne's dose mainly because he's twice
my size
in fact feels offers a free cbd hotline
to help guide your personal experience
so that
you can find your perfect dose the
fields customer service team is
dedicated to making sure you get the
best use of your cbd so
all you got to do is join the fields
monthly membership and that makes your
self-care easy you'll save money on
every order
and you can pause or cancel at any time
so reza here's the important stuff
start feeling better today with feels
become a member by going to feels.com
milkshake and you'll get 50 off your
first order
with free shipping that's right reza
that's
feels f e a l s dot com slash milkshake
to become a member and get 50
automatically taken off your first order
with free shipping
feels.com slash what is it
milkshake i'm not supposed to be doing
ads with my mouth full but this ad is
for the monk pack
keto granola bars and i just can't stop
eating them they are
so good you know healthy snacks they've
got a bad reputation let's be honest
most don't taste
very good they don't fill you up and
they don't satisfy your craving
you know monk pack keto granola bars
contain just one gram of sugar two to
three grams of net carbs and they're
only 140 calories
gluten free grain free plant-based
non-gmo no
soy trans fat sugar alcohols or
artificial colors
they're great for anyone who's following
a keto lifestyle but
they're also the perfect snack for
anybody who's just trying to eat better
or cut back on sugar and carbs without
sacrificing taste
i'm not joking when i say i am obsessed
with these bars
and i eat i would have to say way more
than i'm supposed to
i send it to a subscription to my
favorite flavors and that saved me 10
on every order and also they ship it to
me automatically
get 20 off your first purchase of any
monk pack
product by visiting monkpack.com
and entering our code milkshake at
checkout
and monk pack is so confident in their
product it's backed with a hundred
percent
satisfaction guarantee if you don't like
it for any reason they'll exchange the
product or refund your money
whichever you prefer to get started just
go to m
u n k p a c k monk pack
dot com and select any product then
enter the code milkshake at checkout
to save 20 off your purchase monk pack
delicious nutritious food you can count
on
thank you monk pack for sponsoring this
podcast and keep the bars coming
[Music]
so you know you're um obviously a
spiritual person
you write and talk a lot about
spirituality and all of its various
manifestations i wonder
do you find there to be a connection uh
between
wisdom and spirituality and what and
what what is that connection do you
think
yes my most succinct definition of
spiritual life at its best is
that it is about befriending reality
well okay tell me more that sounds
that's that sounds awesome
yeah i want more of that i want to
befriend reality i want to befriend
reality and not just because i don't
have that many friends that's not why
i'm not interested in spiritual
abstraction
i'm not interested in uh
i'm not interested in spirituality that
doesn't yeah like yeah so in the way
that i care about
lives that in that imprint other lives
faith without works yeah faith without
works that's the way to say it
um but even
i don't know you know you can be deeply
deeply
yes right you can be so you can be very
spiritual and very narcissistic
right and i'm just i'm not interested in
that
i think spiritual our spiritual
traditions that their best spiritual
life
um helps you inhabit reality in
all its complexity and gives you tools
for moving gracefully with that
and you know where where our culture
is constantly trying to help us
be more perfect or overcome obstacles
spiritual life says whatever happens to
you
um in in in within that
um there is growth and learning
possible that you you know
you walk in it and through it and you
let it become part of your wholeness
rather than overcoming and vanquishing
what is hard about reality
and so wise
lives befriend reality they do
they you know the people you know are
wise
are not people who haven't had anything
bad happen to them
right the wisest many of the wisest
people the wisest famous people we could
think of are people to whom the worst
has happened
and they're not wise in spite of that
they have become wise through it
we found a great quote of yours you said
tough-minded spirituality is important
to me it's not fluffy and abstract it is
real
hope is a muscular thing and just love
that quote
and what you're talking about now is
oftentimes very wise people have gone
through tremendous
pain and suffering and somehow they have
transformed it
into wisdom so how do you take
pain and suffering and transform it
up in that direction and not into the
grumpy old man in the trader joe's
parking lot direction
who has probably also suffered because
suffering can
also make our hearts harder and colder
and smaller
yeah the grumpy old man
has gotten old has gotten smaller and
smaller
has shielded themselves has
not faced their demons
um or
asked of what went wrong or what was
hard and you're right i mean there's
something heroic in this too there's
something mysterious and magical in how
human beings do this
and and it's almost insulting when you
think about how many people are going
through unimaginable
just leaving living in unimaginable
conditions to the three of us
to talk about growing through
hardship and yet it is such a mysterious
thing about our world that some of the
people who
live in hardship or live through
hardship teach
become teachers about um
this this reality they're making an
imprint
like you were saying you're making an
imprint right there they're imprinting
the lives of
of those around them there's mystery in
this it's not it's not
it's not simple you know and it's even
hard to talk about for this reason
because it's not like you want like i
want bad things to happen to people so
they get wise isn't it interesting how
probably for all three of us some of the
hardest experiences we have ever had in
our lives we're now
imminently grateful for yes well at the
time it was sheer torture
and we wished like nothing else to be
out of it and how sometimes the things
that
went really right for you turned out to
be just
terrible right and again as you say also
hopefully you can look back later and
say i'm glad i went through that because
it
pointed me in this other way i needed to
walk
well can i can i ask you a question that
you would normally ask someone
who would have said something give an
example yeah one of your yeah one of
your listeners
uh which is yeah without necessarily you
know revealing too much
uh can you point to uh
uh something that's very specific that
you some wisdom that you gained from
hardship that has allowed you to then
imprint that wisdom
onto others especially of course i mean
you've grown kids so i imagine that's
a very important part of um you know who
you are as a as a parent and as a person
yeah i suppose the thing that comes to
mind is um
in my mid-30s i had a really serious
clinical depression
and uh of course
yeah it's a perfect example because if
you had told me
i mean at the time you know it's this
experience of
i just wanted out of that dark place
right and i
and the thing about depression is you
can't even imagine that there's a beyond
of it
it's not it's not that you can't even
get there as you can't imagine that
there's a beyond of it
um and i don't wish that for anyone but
it's also true at this point that i
don't think i could have done
most of what i ended up doing that has
felt like my life's
work uh much less maybe bennett
you know not that i don't think i think
parenting is constantly
you're one is constantly aware of how
one is falling short so i'm not saying
i'm a good parent
but i would have been a less good parent
um
if i hadn't learned everything that this
depression you know it brought me to my
knees for me
it was things that i needed to um
see in my uh you know things i just
hadn't told the truth about
and that my family hadn't told the truth
about and the way i had
survived really vigorously and kind of
valiantly in a way but
but driven myself into the ground
and um i am i mean i look back and think
if i hadn't had that depression
i i would have had a lesser life
which is an incredible thing to say
even though i also have a sense of you
know near escape
there's this there's this thing that
brene brown says that
um there's science about how hope is
actually
a function of struggle and that when
people
have not met adversity one of the
effects of that
is that they become hopeless interesting
yeah wow yeah yeah that's powerful
that's powerful
and weird it's interesting because that
um i'm a member of the baha'i faith and
one of the quotes on raising children is
from the son of the founder of the
baha'i faith
and he says quite simply let your
children
become accustomed to hardship and
adversity yeah
and it's like wait what because in
contemporary society it's like
let's helicopter away any hardship and
adversity
that a kid might be going through but in
a way there's such a wisdom
wisdom behind what you're saying that
um having gone through adversity and
come out on the other side
gives you hope like hey we can go
through really hard times and we can
survive and we can even
we can even thrive and that what you
just said is another
it's another way of saying befriend
reality let them befriend reality
reality has sharp edges reality is not
waiting
to cuddle you and and pave
pave a seamless way forward for you
yeah so speaking of learning wisdom
um and this is why i was so excited to
have you
on the show as you have literally spoken
to hundreds of the wisest people on the
planet
i was thinking namely and i forget the
gentleman's name
he lived in france and he started the
home for
people with uh mental issues and
physical challenges i
can't remember oh yeah jean vanier and
xavier le pichon was another one who
worked in those communities yeah and it
just com
so with such humility and kindness and
sweetness and
purity of spirit that spent his entire
life
serving the less fortunate um just
incredibly beautiful discussions but
what have you learned
krista what did you glean from all of
these dozens and dozens of conversations
with
you know mary oliver yo-yo ma ta-nehisi
coates
it goes on and on monks reza aslam
reza aslan oh dear lord help us
now i don't even want to say what did
you learn from them because you could
say well i had this quote or something
like that but what did you
learn like what how have any of these
conversations
transformed your life and
shifted how you are in the world and
experiencing
people who are wise
and and you know admirable
right deeply admirable um
there's a there's a physical
experience of them which is of
of of strength and power
and tenderness and softness
and those things
don't go together in our culture
it's a it's it's almost a confusing
experience
but in life to really flourish in life
and to both have your feet on the ground
and love to fail
and grow we actually
need all both of those capacities and
i think and there's so many ways i could
talk about what i've learned but i think
that
i think almost palpably you know picking
up that
ability to hold these seemingly opposing
qualities
in a creative interplay has kind of
invited me to uh cultivate that creative
inner plan
myself even when it really is
counter-cultural
and it's not even necessarily
comfortable right it
but it's i think it's the way to live
[Music]
folks nowadays most small business
owners are busier than ever because
they're focused on managing and growing
their businesses
they can't be spending time recruiting
and hiring people
that's why linkedin jobs has made it
easier to find and hire the best
candidates for
free back in the day when i was applying
for jobs there was no such thing as
linkedin
it was terrible you'd have to look
through actual newspapers
there was not a central source like
linkedin jobs
to which in which through which to apply
and through which to hire oh goodness
gracious
how far we've come that's right so get
started by posting your job for free to
reach
lincoln's network of million
professionals
fill out targeted screening questions to
get your role in front of the most
qualified candidates with the experience
skills and motivation
you need and then it's easy to filter
and prioritize the top candidates you'd
like to interview
linkedin jobs will help you hire the
right person for your role
did you know every week nearly 40
million job seekers visit linkedin
post your first job for free at
linkedin.com slash
milkshake that's linkedin.com slash
milkshake
to post your first job for free terms
and conditions apply
hey milkshakers listen sun's out
buns out and hopefully
any stray hairs are also not
out don't worry our friends at manscaped
have got you covered
they've just launched their fourth
generation performance package
reza i've never been a big one for
personal grooming but recently i have
had to
pay attention to what is going on in
this manly landscape
of mine but you seem pretty smooth
underneath
these clothes i am silken smooth
no i've got enough hair on my body
to fill like a fairly good sized king
size pillow
the performance package 4.0 includes the
new lawnmower 4.0 this trimmer will
change the way
you approach your entire grooming
routine i have used it
it works fantastically and it's also
waterproof so you can trim in the shower
and not worry about your cleanup on
aisle d
so folks get 20 off and free shipping
when you use the code milkshake at
manscape.com that's 20
off plus free shipping and all you got
to do is use the code
milkshake when you go to manscape.com so
tame that summer swamp in your pants
with manscaped and yes i just said that
so i wonder if um you know
all this thought that you have given to
wisdom and
all the wise people that you've spoken
to and
if there's sort of any really good
advice that you could give
to rain and me about
you know because i feel like we're both
we're both in that middle
like the laterest stages of our lives
right i mean
i'm almost 50 rain is almost 70.
yeah right he looks great for 70.
people say it all the time people are
always like rain you look amazing
i am wise but that is not gonna stop me
from kicking your ass
no but in all seriousness i mean you
know this is something that that ray and
i
have been talking about uh you know the
wisdom that
we have accumulated over the last couple
of years the wisdom that
we could maybe one day pass down to our
children
what advice would you give us for how we
can
foster wisdom more in our lives
ah again you're asking me these huge
questions but
what comes from yeah it doesn't feel
that great to have the tables turned
does it does it krista yeah much easier
to ask
big questions i think
a really basic move
that you're that you're both making but
again
it's it's counter cultural and
everything about the way we structure
we our lives are structured kind of dick
kind of works against this which is to
to keep alive this both the movement
outward and the movement inward
and um
to to to yes look you
are we are all as you some one of you
said we're not we're not monastics here
right we are leading lives in the world
we are leading big lives in the world
and also doing this multitasking of
our personal lives and our professional
lives um
but to
to cultivate this connection between
inner life and outer presence in the
world
as a back and forth um
and i think for people like us and i
mean even more so at your
ages because i think you're in the
middle it i think at my age which is
really i mean
getting older is has a lot to to uh
to to to save forward it's you know it's
amazing and it gets it starts to get a
little bit
less of a tension for me it does take me
longer to pee
i have to say but otherwise yes but in
the middle of life
it's hard to to pay that attention
to to your inward
life to keeping alive a vision of what
kind of human being you want to be
to getting conscious about
what kind of muscle memory you need to
flex to be that person
it's very it's a very moment to moment
um yeah and it's a quality of attention
it's it's that equality of attention and
curiosity even curiosity about yourself
you know these are moral muscles
actually
that they take effort i love this whole
idea that spirituality is not some kind
of
airy fairy you know mystical concept
that doesn't have practical
applications and i've already heard a
couple of things from you that uh
really uh sparked my kind of spiritual
imagination
earlier on you were talking about
virtues that you
one can train them you know one can
just because you're impatient doesn't
mean you can't become more patient you
can just put
some focus and attention on to
patients and cultivating that quality of
patience within oneself
and then you just also said in your
words of advice to
reign and reza about them cultivating
their their wisdom
they keep alive the movement outward and
the movement inward and i i think that's
so beautiful because
um sometimes people think about like
well living my best life is all outward
it's all about
doing and it's all about solving and
fixing and working
and and increasing pay and status and
um and reaching outside of themselves
sometimes it's
selfish and sometimes it's selfless but
it's always an
out external move and then some to some
people
kind of more in like the maybe the yoga
communities it's more
just inward like spirituality is i want
some peace and serenity inside of myself
so i'm going to do this meditation
practice or whatever but those those two
movements
they're kind of the yin and the yang
complementary movements
aren't in sync but we're doing both at
the same time
we're we're doing more in the outside
world and we're doing more
in the inside world yeah and also
something i want to say that
has really been a new realization for me
that
it's so interesting in the history of
the show every once in a while there's
just some
idea or theme that rises up and suddenly
everyone i talk to is talking about it
even though they're completely different
they're coming from different directions
and the thing
now is um
about you know that that
turn inward is it's not it's not
aesthetic
it's not it's not about bearing down on
being a good person i mean there's some
of that right there's some of that
saying i am going to act more
compassionate even if i don't feel like
it
but the the theme that's rising up now
is this theme of
joy and delight as
resilience making life-giving
experiences
that even if we are going to devote our
lives to
pursuing justice
that we and you know this is a this is a
teaching for our time right because
there's so much we can see that needs to
be better there's so much that needs to
be fought or repaired
right but this the wellspring of that
needs to be knowing what we love
and it and also the work ahead is long
right this is generational work ahead
this transformation that we that we need
and i think most of us long for
even if we don't know how to step onto
it and so
another thing another feature of that
inner move needs to be that we
let ourselves get replenished and
rested um so
some of it is about being kind inwardly
which is a relief
thank you so much uh uh
we're gonna have a lot to talk about
it's just beautiful beautiful way but we
can't let you go yet
because uh it's time for the lightning
round questions
i'm really excited i'm really bad at
these every everybody's bad at them
i don't know why we do it it's mostly to
torture people i think
krista tippett when do you feel most
connected with the universe
when i'm with my children and remember
my children are grown so i'm not with
them all the time
it's a special occasion what's one thing
you would change about yourself if you
could
i would be less of a worrier
what is america a great unrealized
possibility okay if hollywood was making
a biopic about your life
who would play you and what would it be
called
well one day i want to write my berlin
novel and my stasi file
my strazi files which are this high
which were kept on me
because they just they thought i was
much more interesting than i actually
was
they gave the the east german stasi gave
me the name
she-wolf that was my code name
called she-wolf who would play this
young version of you in the in their 20s
going through a checkpoint charlie well
what about um
how do you schwarze ronan
oh yeah that's a good one oh nice i'm
going to confess to this because this is
probably never going to happen i
thought if i write my berlin novel and
it's a movie
i'd like her to play me if you could
live during
any historical moment which one would it
be
this one this one come on
this is an amazing time to be alive but
you know what's funny
is yeah actually this is a very
pivotal moment in human history that
we're all living in so it's actually a
pretty good answer
well a question that goes hand in hand
with that is if you could have lunch
with any author past or present who
would it be
and why well i'd like to have lunch with
einstein but i suspect that he would be
really disappointing
to have lunch with but i'd still like to
try it
in his later more philosophical years
he'd probably be hitting on the waitress
that's right all right if you could have
coffee with the 15 year old krista
tippett
what would you tell her oh i would tell
her to let herself
take pleasure and not
be so driven i would like i would tell
her to let to enjoy
when things are enjoyable let that let
it be enjoyable have fun
also invest in apple that's what you
would tell 15 year old reza
what is one eye-opening experience every
person should have
no you have stumped me i don't think
there's anything everybody should have
honestly because i could say having
children but that's not something
everybody should do i mean for me
you know completely altered my dna
eye opening but i don't think it you
know i don't i wouldn't say everybody
should do this
and then finally what is your life's big
question
yeah i don't know how to keep living
gracefully
that's actually a really good one that's
a great one i think you're doing an
exceptional
job of living gracefully thank you rain
that means a lot christa as you know
i've been fanboying out on you and your
podcast and
um there it looks like there's a new
horizon ahead
so the on being project will be
launching an app in
early july uh this is this is really
uh exciting it's it looks like there's
it's an interactive
kind of experience with on being what is
this new chapter of on being
yes we're launching a wisdom app whoa
yeah it's exciting it's connected to
related to this conversation
and and it's course based
um and the first course is hope is a
muscle
and and it's
to me it's it's it's it's
speaking into this moment we are
entering
coming out of this pandemic year uh
most of us not everybody in the world um
with all that we have been called to
learn
and how do we hold on to how do we hold
on to those questions right and keep
living them it's gonna be really easy to
default back
and how do we hold the highest visions
we have for ourselves
and for our country and for our children
and the places we live
and yeah hope is a muscle
um and what i also love about doing with
this first of all it's
it's i get to be in the role of a
teacher which i
which i'm which is fun and i didn't know
if i could do it but i've really enjoyed
it but i'm
teaching alongside the wise people
who are in on the show and
what i love about i i'm excited about
this it's new
um is that everybody who's in the app
that we're kind of going to be on
kind of walking this together and
and um learning and taking
kind of practical tools practical ways
to to
to live hopefully um
and pragmatically and kind of doing it
together
and people have always asked us you know
people have always wanted us to take on
being to another stage right kind of
give us something we can use
and that we can do together so that's
the experiment
with the app what a great idea so
basically it's
you're taking the the content from on
being
and then you're developing kind of like
course based
uh guided um participatory experiences
out of those um that of that content and
it's you know it's 10 to 15 minutes
of a wisdom practice which is manageable
that's the max of my attention level
right there and then there's also a
contemplative aspect to it
so we're kind of entering this wellness
space in the app world
and there's a lot of good stuff there
most of it is about meditation
mindfulness and sleep
and meditation and mindfulness
are revolutionizing the world but they
there's more to wisdom
right than than meditating and so we're
trying
you know what i what i'm interested in
is this matter of how we can cultivate
becoming the people we want to be
and creating some community around that
so that's the idea
it's called the on being project and the
wisdom app
christa tippett it has been an absolute
joy and honor
to have you on the show thank you for
joining us on metaphysical milkshake
thanks so much thank you guys what an
honor wow i don't know about you
rain but i feel wiser yeah i'm none the
wiser
you did didn't help at all right no that
was a great conversation i got a lot out
of it that really
it sparked my imagination it moved my
heart um what
what did you how do you feel wiser what
what what happened for you
i mean look it's an unanswerable
question and we admitted that it was an
unanswerable question what is wisdom
uh but then she went and answered it and
she answered it really well and she also
answered it in my favorite way
that any any any time you're asked one
of these like incredibly difficult
questions like what is faith
what is hope what is love
what is wisdom if the answer
doesn't include some version of
a thing that you put into the world
actions that you perform
right then i'm not interested in the
answer and i love that that was like her
immediate thing right her immediate
thing was well it's the imprint that you
that you create that's what wisdom is
yeah um it's what you do and so the
thing that really hit me was this kind
of
that it's a the movement inward that
then
reflects outward
and i have to say like if i'm thinking
about you know uh
not just like you know what i learned
about this conversation but what i've
learned about
you know wisdom or if i've become wiser
over these last two years of living in
this kind of
covid nightmare experience um
it is a little bit to do with that like
to me i feel like
i'm sorry if i'm if i'm going on here
for a little bit but i'm used to it
yeah yeah exactly i'll i'll i'll let you
talk eventually
um no keep going i'm interested covet
happened in this
really weird time for me because it was
you know like a a year after the debacle
with you know cnn and losing this show
that i basically spent like 10 years of
my life
you know putting together uh and then
it was finally around that time where
you know
that had settled down and it would you
know i felt like i could kind of
uh re-emerge and kind of re-engage
uh with that world of like hosting and
then i had this sort of
this talk show that we that i was doing
that we did a first season of and then
we couldn't do a second season of
because of kovid like
i felt as though the 16 17 months or so
that i kind of was forced
to close everything down and go
inward professionally speaking came at a
at the wrong time so outwardly
the outward came at the wrong time
but and you and i have talked about this
before
inwardly this has been a really special
time
you know like knowing that that i can't
be out there that i can't get my face
out there
and so learning to just kind of get rid
of that
and ignore that and then focus
inward and just and also like focus on
the laser on being like
the best dad that i could be the best
husband that i could be
and then also like it's kind of nice
like having my kids and my wife
actually remark upon that like wow we've
we noticed something different about you
wow i got the benefit of
yeah this uh this wiser more focused
more present reza
i i i feel like i and then now of course
as we're getting back out into the world
i uh i want to take that with me so
i feel like yes did i gain wisdom yes
did i gain wisdom by sort of
focusing on the movement inward yeah i
did
am i ready for that inward movement to
now express itself
outward into the world yeah i am so
i'm just saying that i i think krista
tippett would be proud of me that's
that's great that's great what about you
what about you
have you do you feel wiser over these
last uh you know year and a half or so
is there some
aspect of wisdom that you feel like
you've gained based on what krista has
taught us
yeah again i want to go back to this
idea about
she said because i wrote it down on my
little notepad keep alive the movement
outward and the movement inward
yeah that's when covid first hit
i was like a kid in a candy store i was
really excited i was so productive
like i wrote a whole scripted podcast i
wrote half of a book i
you know i was i outlined a complete
horror
screenplay like i was just like chugging
along i did a talk show on soul pancake
and um it was great and then
you know over the course of kovid really
i would say over the last like three to
four months like
i've struggled and i think the lesson
for me was kind of like
oh i got a little cocky i got a little
arrogant i thought i had my [ __ ]
together
and realizing like oh my actually my
mental health
is a lot more fragile than than i
thought it was and there's been some
real
struggles in this last quarter of the
pandemic
that has that has made me kind of stop
had to stop and say okay you need to
stop focusing so much your focus
on the movement outward and you need to
start
refocusing in your movement inward
because we don't
tend to that garden then it all goes to
[ __ ] so
it was it was kind of a good wake-up
call for me like oh
i need to tend to my inner garden of
peace and that's
prayer meditation some kind of practice
self-care um reconnecting to my purpose
in the world staying grounded
um and just how important
that is for me if i if i want to have
any movement outward
no it's weird so you know we're kind of
like meeting in the middle aren't we
we are sort of yeah yeah beautiful that
it's beautiful well um what a
fascinating conversation
all around um i got so much out of it
and
thank you krista tippett for doing this
deep dive with the metaphysical
milkshake
team we'd love to hear what you guys
have to say what
what is wisdom to you and
how specifically do you think we can get
wisdom and what wisdom have you
potentially gotten over this last year
year and a half of this
of this horrible pandemic we would love
to hear from you isn't that right reza
you know as you can imagine we we got a
lot of voicemails
on the topic of wisdom people had a lot
to say
about wisdom but there's one that
actually really caught our attention
we got a voicemail from a mary ponti uh
let's let's take a listen to that
hi my name is mary i'm from baltimore
maryland and
i was thinking about what wisdom is what
the purpose of it is
and i was thinking about a sentiment
that oprah winfrey
mentioned in her super soul
conversations about how the universe is
constantly trying to
give us wisdom by teaching us lessons
and that
starts out whispering and when we don't
hear it it gets louder and louder until
we listen however she said that once we
think
that we've learned a lesson that's when
we need to keep learning
it once you think you've mastered
something
you're actually not there and you still
need to practice what the universe has
been teaching you
so i just kind of wonder where wisdom
lies within that
is it the process of learning
i used to think of it as an end point
and i think it's interesting to think
about
what is wisdom then if it's something
that we can never get to
is it a journey itself of experiencing
things is it continual growth is it
piling the messages from the universe
together
and when do we actually ever reach
wisdom so that's what i've been
contemplating
um for example i have
many well i'm running out of time but
i've had many experiences where
i just keep learning what i thought i've
already learned before and
keep gaining more wisdom or what i think
is wisdom so
thank you so much i'm looking forward to
hearing the episode have a great day
we love that voicemail so much we called
our producers and we're like we have to
get
this mary prunty whatever her name is
on the show so ten thousand dollars and
two restraining orders later
she is here we've got her on the show
welcome mary
yay hello it's so great to be here thank
you so much
the question you asked was really
fantastic and
i loved this idea about talking about
wisdom as a journey as a process rather
than a destination and an
end point and that was a really
beautiful perspective have you
dealt with this yourself mary in your
personal life
you know i feel like growing up you hear
wisdom constantly
um you say it's even like you learn at a
young age
that wisdom exists because it's like
associated with like the wisdom of an
owl and then you hear about it in books
you always say you always hear listen to
your elders because they have wisdom to
share with you
and so i feel like it's kind of this
thing you hear over and over but you
don't
understand what it is until you start to
experience
something like that um so i've
been trying to grapple with my place in
the universe
and in that i've been trying to listen
to
the lessons and along the way
when things have happened i've been
trying to figure out what am i supposed
to learn from this
which is hard in itself to accept that
you need to learn something from it
because that means that you have to
admit that you're
kind of maybe doing something not wrong
but you could be doing something
differently
or maybe you're not on your correct path
at that very moment
so um i've just been trying to figure
out
what i can learn from things and but i'm
scared to admit that i've learned them
at the same time because of what oprah
says that once you think you've learned
something that's when the universe is
going to tell you
you haven't learned it yet um
slow down and listen again because it
will come back and you all have to learn
more
wisdom whatever that means so you know i
appreciate the fact that you bring up uh
oprah
in this or as i like to call her my
friend oprah
i love what you know this whole idea
that she has she talks about it in a lot
of different ways not just in the
context of wisdom but in the
notion of like learning to be at one
with the universe thinking of the
universe is kind of like this
river that's floating past and
and to not sort of swim against the tide
or to fight it but to just kind of
allow it to move you along that that's
how you know you're on the right path
that's now you know you're
you're doing the right thing that you're
gaining wisdom it's something that i
actually think about
a lot but i was curious what you thought
about krista tippett's point
about wisdom being about the
impact that you make on other people
right that it's about it's an active
idea it's a
thing that you put into the world um
not just a thing that you take from the
world
i think that's a beautiful way to look
at wisdom and what i love about that
is it's connective because i do believe
that everything in the universe is
connected and so when you share
your experiences in your life with other
people and you share your wisdom
with other people or lessons that
if that is the wisdom then you're giving
the world a gift that it gave to you
because
i mean if you think about it maybe
wisdom doesn't even exist
until you put it out there because i
don't know what wisdom you have
and that you could share with the world
i think about
someone like like oprah winfrey who has
been through
everything and without her
being vulnerable and sharing her
experiences and leaving that impact on
the world we wouldn't have that wisdom
we wouldn't have all the lives she's
touched and all of the people she's
impacted
and um i wouldn't be here having this
conversation with you guys if it weren't
for
the impact of her actions and
both of your actions on super soul
conversations and
everything so i i think that's beautiful
to think of it that way thank you for
your wonderful question and your
beautiful observations and
thanks for joining us on metaphysical
milkshake thank you so much
thanks mary you know how to find us
we're on
socials at reza aslan at rayne wilson
the show
is on twitter at metamilkpodcast it's on
instagram at metaphysicalmilkshake
let us know you know shoot us uh shoot
us a little message uh tell us
um what you think about uh christa's
definition of wisdom
and also tell us about other big
questions that you want us to tackle on
this show
and we might use them in future episodes
and remember to follow rate and review
metaphysical milkshake on apple podcasts
please write the little review just take
take a few seconds if you like the show
it helps us a great deal
and it's a way to foster wisdom that
would
you will be so much the wiser for it uh
you can also subscribe to the
metaphysical milkshake youtube channel
and instead of listening you can watch
our episodes
and watch us yapping away every week
you should do this because you know
we've been listening to krista tippett
all you know for like two decades
and like seeing her face that was that
was fun right it was fun seeing your
face she's a lovely
lovely woman that's right she looks
vivacious and bright and
and uh we are not vivacious nor bright
no but you can still look at us uh
but until then uh we'll see you next
week
[Music]
metaphysical milkshake is executive
produced by rayne wilson reza aslan and
colin thompson
it's produced by safa samezadeh yaz
harris lane
nick hashem self and dj lubell
cast media is the production and
distribution partner it is edited by
tyler newbold and audio mixed by justin
kyle
original music is composed by jeff tank
i was on a tv show i don't know if you
know that i heard
friends we all we've all seen it every
time i post
people like oh my god it's so old and
like guys
it is no longer 2007.